se c'è una cosa che mi piace fare oltre
inquadrature inutilmente belle e
raccontare una storia così come scritto
sul copione magari enfatizzando alcuni
punti e cercando di renderla
interessante anche quando potrebbe
essere inutile per chiunque stia
ascoltando quello che voglio raccontarvi
oggi è una storia orribile veramente
pessima sotto ogni punto di vista un
inizio vago uno sviluppo che ha confuso
tutti quanti e un finale che si vedrà
soltanto fra qualche anno però
nonostante tutto mi ha fatto cagare in
mano perché tutto quello che c'è qui
tutte le persone che lavorano tutti
tutti gli elementi tutte le strutture lo
studio la sedia potrebbero finire da un
momento all'altro così come quello che
faccio io di lavoro presa che divertente
e come ho detto il finale non si sa ed è
quello il problema però partiamo
dall'inizio
[Musica]
e il 23 marzo e sono appena tornato a
torino da milano perchè avremmo dovuto
girare un video sull'articolo 13 ma ho
scoperto che il 26 ci sarà
l'approvazione o no dell'articolo quindi
credo sarebbe inutile fare un video a
far uscire adesso per un video adesso
quindi io aspetterei comunque è palese
che la situazione non sia normale perché
sul web sta per succedere qualcosa su
internet è stato riesumato un discorso
che sembrava essere molto mesi prima
l'articolo 13
torniamo indietro circa novembre
dicembre 2018 e cercate di ricordare
cosa ci fosse nelle tendenze in quel
periodo
a parte lo youtube dei wine quel
capolavoro d'arte moderna che è stato
apprezzato da tutti si parlava della
cosiddetta morte di youtube per questo
benedetto articolo 13 la visione del
mondo era diventata immediatamente
apocalittica youtube sta per finire
youtube cuber caro articolo 13 stai per
distruggere youtube
rischiamo di chiudere tutti youtube
annuncia la sua fine che all'inizio si
erano di video di informazione per far
capire la gente la gravità di questo
articolo 13 ma è bastato poco per far
diventare il tutto una corsa alla
chiatto di views e volendo potete farlo
anche voi a casa basta procurarsi logo
che youtube utilizza quando rimuove un
video tagliarlo a metà preferibilmente a
zig zag ottenere sollevate le due parti
e mettersi in posa fare una faccia tipo
mi sono appena ricordato che il canale
sta morendo quindi mi tocca fare un
anteprima di merda per attirare la gente
scattare la foto scrivere un titolo che
faccio a cagare in mano tutti a domare a
piacere e tutto sembrava un periodo di
passaggio ma come ho detto prima il 23
marzo è ripartito l'argomento più forte
che mai e non soltanto dagli youtubers
ma da tutto il web e non solo facendo
delle ricerche per questo video ho
scoperto che c'è un calendario di città
europee che manifesteranno per strada
oggi è anche una petizione online di
change.org che arrivata a oltre 5
milioni di firme
se solo servissero a qualcosa con le
petizioni
[Musica]
so che probabilmente avrete le palle
piene di sentir parlare di questo
argomento però per capire cosa ho
provato io
bisogna avere tutti i dettagli io sono
uno di quelli che non si è mai
preoccupato troppo di questa situazione
perché sarebbe impossibile la chiusura
di siti come youtube facebook instagram
e compagnia bella anche se l'articolo
venisse approvato ci sarebbero
sicuramente delle protezioni per
impedire la distruzione del web a costo
di essere uno degli ultimi stronzi a
parlarne
vi spiego in modo banale banale in cosa
consisterebbe questo articolo internet
decide che le piattaforme come youtube
debbano controllare preventivamente i
contenuti postati facendo in modo che in
cento per cento nei contenuti siano di
proprietà di chi li ha caricati per
salvaguardare i diritti degli artisti a
cui la gente ruba i lavori prendiamo
youtube che quello che interessa la
maggior parte di noi
secondo una statistica su youtube
vengono caricati oltre 300 ore di
contenuti
al minuto prima di caricare il video
youtube deve assicurarsi che tutto il
contenuto al suo interno sia di tua
proprietà ed è ovviamente impossibile
cosa comporta non che youtube chiuda ma
che sicuramente cambi praticamente solo
youtube originals no quelli che nessuno
guarda
l'alternativa sarebbe fare contenuti al
cento per cento di tua proprietà
un'utopia
bisognerebbe farsi le musiche e le sigle
le immagini e stare attenti ai vestiti e
cercare di intrattenere comunque rtrt
rete tech 3 ter detector
c'è una scena del film che c'è un pranzo
delle finestre e poi c'è quel mostro
giapponese è quello gigante che lo
distruggeva una fiammata
ma gli effetti speciali sono terribili e
ancora cliccati cliccate il tasto
iscrivetevi
mi raccomando e lasciar line non posso
dire like mi raccomando iscrivetevi e
lasciate un pollice all'insù non avrei
mai pensato di dirlo in una puntata
dello show ma youtube potrebbe diventare
come quella puntata di due fantagenitori
dove tutto diventa grigio e senza
identità paura da quanto si applaude
bile ma appunto è impossibile se fosse
così grave ne parlerebbero molto di più
anche altri siti uno dei contenuti più
toccati da questa legge sarebbero il
gameplay visto che in quel caso quasi il
100 per cento del contenuto non è tuo
dovrebbero parlarne loro siti come trish
appena messo un banner sul loro sito che
parla proprio dell'articolo 13 quindi
anche loro sono abbastanza preoccupate e
non solo anche pornhub ammesso
un'immagine gigantesca nella loro
homepage che dice se vuoi salvare si può
entrare in guerra con noi per salvare
internet clicca qui insomma selezione a
preoccuparmi davvero il 25 marzo è stato
un punto di svolta per me dal
chissenefrega
ok potrei perdere il lavoro ho avuto
altre occasioni per parlare di quali
siano i miei sentimenti verso questo
tipo di occupazione ed ogni volta che
l'ho fatto molti altri credo giustamente
mi hanno dato contro dicendomi che non
posso parlare a nome di tutte quindi
parlo per me
negli ultimi due anni mi e sanità
addosso una paura [ __ ] per il mio
futuro è quel 25 marzo ha peggiorato la
cosa quando ho scoperto che chi piglia
ha bloccato l'intero sito oggi per
protesta tra virgolette ma soprattutto
per mettere l'attenzione sull'articolo
la cosa è seria servirebbe un parere
esterno perché il problema più grande di
tutta questa situazione e che ne sta
parlando la gente ma non i diretti
interessati
per esempio cliccando su act now di
pornhub si arriva ad una pagina che ti
spiega per filo e per segno
tutto poco più in basso c'è un'immagine
dei difensori di internet un gruppo di
parlamentari europei che si stanno
battendo per evitare che l'articolo 13
passi
sarebbe incredibile se riuscissimo a
metterci in contatto con almeno io non
penso che youtube chiuderà ma si troverà
a diventare non so una sorta di netflix
diventerà un canale una piattaforma solo
per contenuti preparati e sistemati su
tutti i fronti rispetto a diciamole il
diritto di copyright
il rischio rispetto alla attuazione
effettiva della direttiva se fosse
approvata è proprio quello del caos ogni
paese potrebbe dare tempi diversi dare
una forma di attuazione differente nei
limiti diciamo dati dalla direttiva
stessa portando così in chiave difensiva
gli attori di internet le piattaforme a
censurare ancora di più proprio per
evitare di essere scoperti rispetto non
coperti dal punto di vista del rispetto
della legge rispetto a un attuazione che
rischia di essere molto caotica per
aggravare ulteriormente le cose
quindi è molto più grave del previsto
grazie ad aguero quindi e incrociamo le
dita
ma si sa che chi vive sperando
aggiornamento del 26 marzo 2019
all'una di pomeriggio è stata approvata
o no è stata approvata la legge alla
strasburgo hanno detto di sì
348 si 274 no e 36 astenuti il
parlamento europeo approva la direttiva
sul diritto digitale d'autore direttiva
europea del diritto d'autore in
parlamento di strasburgo approva
definitivamente voi un bicchiere di vino
ma non ai vino e sarebbe il momento
giusto per iniziare a bere copyright
parlamento europeo approva la riforma
equo compenso a chi detiene i diritti
d'autore è quindi è finita però c'è
scritto che c'è una norma salva me me
c'è scritto su questa notizia di rainews
salva meme salvamamme poi il caricamento
e la condivisione di opere protette a
scopo di citazione critica revisione
caricatura parodia sarà sempre possibile
condivisibile sulle piattaforme online
però quasi parla di appena scritto
simone diciamo che siamo tutti un
pochino preoccupanti ecco perché non ho
continuato a studiare perché nel 2013 e
20 metri di guardare il canale nel suo
complesso dire ma sai che con la
monetizzazione potrei farlo a tempo
pieno [ __ ] perché non ho continuato
a studiare ma perché non ho fatto altro
anche tutti hanno fatto i libri riviste
e diari e zaini hanno fatto programmi in
tv sono andati al cinema hanno fatto la
radio e io non so scrivere neanche il
mio curriculum perché cazzo non mi è
venuto in mente prima ma con tutti i
problemi che ha la piattaforma con tutte
le monetizzazioni con gli hub l'ok il
boca lips e contenta il minimo che cazzo
mi è venuto in mente io voglio fare
quello che fa ellen hidding voglio fare
quello che fa e le voglio fare melaverde
io lo voglio però non voglio avere
responsabilità non voglio non voglio
crescere lo voglio diventare un luogo
non voglio avere responsabilità perché
non è bello avere così tante
responsabilità e stai attento che se il
video piace e non piace e se i noioso e
cale al canale perché se va male e
finita è finita
io mi baso tutta la mia vita su voi se
vuoi
dice se tutti e quanto un milione e 400
mila persone oggi non ho voglia di
guardare youtube fatto puntualmente se
non guardate questo video non è finita
io voglio fare come me voglio essere
pagato per un programma noiosissimo è
sempre noioso per melaverde io voglio
fare melaverde voglio andare via a
parlare con le mucche e parlare di
quanto siano naturale cibi che fanno i
contadini perché non gliela sbatte il
cazzo a nessuno la gente lo guarda
passiva perché non esiste una puntata
belle una puntata brutta di melaverde
non c'è una puntata da noioso dove india
intersse fanno un saab reddit dove
chiudeva a farlo la vita e non puoi
uscire di casa perché tutti ed insultano
è un programma non uso sempre ma è
sicuro
e qui ci ricolleghiamo a quello che ho
detto all'inizio del video il finale di
questa storia lo vedremo soltanto fra
qualche anno quando entreranno in vigore
i veri effetti di questa legge
per ora possiamo soltanto rasserenarci
leggendo i commenti sotto i video di
altri contente eto'o infatti a dicembre
perché anche voi pubblico a modo vostro
avete combattuto questa battaglia laica
chi vuole che sia bandita questa legge
laiche se vuoi che youtube non finisca
io o lui o senza i vostri video mi
dispiace che mi crede che sto piangendo
metà laiche commenta ma soprattutto un
like uguale un giorno in più che durerà
youtube e guardate 410 like quindi
abbiamo un po più di un anno di tempo
per stare tranquilli grazie agli autori
x07 ne avevo sinceramente bisogno